Christopher Columbus was a very great
man and one of the most consequential
figures to ever live on planet Earth he
quite easily had more of an impact than
every single one of his modern critics
combined times a thousand these are the
people that we give holidays to or used
to the people who shape the world and
say whatever else you want about
Columbus he did more than almost any
other single person in history to shape
the world we live in today now it's
often said by idiots who claim to be
intellectually nuanced that if Columbus
did achieve this worldshaping feat he
did it accidentally now even if that's
true it wouldn't change his significance
or the significance of what he
accomplished but it's not true he may
have been looking for the East Indies in
other words he was looking for land he
knew existed rather than looking for
land he didn't know existed so could not
have been looking for by definition but
there there was nothing accidental about
his V voyage